well this one came out of nowhere right
Intel is launching two budget orientated
graphics cards The Arc b580 and
b570 they've automatically caught our
attention for two reasons number one
they're undercutting AMD and Nvidia in
the sub $300 Market secondly they're not
skimping on vram 12 gigs of memory is
positively luxurious at b580
$250 price point while Intel reckons
performance is on average 10 percentage
points ahead of the RTX 4060 an 8
gigabyte card that retails for $300 220
USD for the 10 GB
b570 not seen it yet but the haircut to
Specs looks reasonable in terms of
bandwidth compute and vram could be a
bit of a winner especially if the perf
differential is anything like
a570 versus a770 from back in the day
still claims are one thing real world
performance May well be another the GPU
itself I'll keep this brief but the
reference card is excellent extremely
quiet in operation so well apart from
entry level third party cards for sure
there's one 8 Pin pcie power input three
display ports one HDMI 2.1 so a bit of
background here at digital Foundry we've
been revamping our benchmarking behind
the scenes and I'm going to level with
you we weren't expecting new gpus to
arrive this soon we have big plans for
our Hardware reviews but you're only
going to see a hint of them in this
review but we've got a new bunch of
games and we've automated benchmarks to
varying degrees so for the likes of Alan
Wake 2 here we've even made our own
Benchmark run traversing a challenging
area of the game we've also moved away
from video capture based benchmarking in
favor of Nvidia frame view which is
built on the open source present mod and
this opens up a wealth of data how about
realtime tracking of power consumption
from both PCI slot and pcie power cables
we can do that now it's one thing to say
that different gpus may have similar
performance levels but what if one is
drawing a ton more power than the other
now we can visualize that and if a game
supports Nvidia reflex developers have
to introduce markers into the code and
this means that regardless of whether
the game's running on an Nvidia GPU or
not we can now track PC latency and plot
it alongside performance automating
benchmarks means we can do more
interesting stuff too it's typical just
to bench everything at Ultra across the
major resolutions right but should we be
doing that for a $250 GPU Well for now
we will be but check this out a plag to
recm at 4K resolution on the b580 not
exactly groundbreaking performance at
native 4K Ultra right uh is
significantly faster if we switch to
optimized settings and those optimized
settings some draw distance tweaks apart
are very close to PlayStation 5 settings
so if we use those in combination with a
soos's reconstruction based upscaler
used on consoles and creating a 4K image
from a 1440p input well suddenly our
$250 Intel GPU is outperforming consoles
and what is it in PC terms a compelling
1080p GPU can actually do pretty well on
a 4K screen so yeah by and large we will
be using standard established
methodology in this review But
ultimately we will be moving on to a
more holistic view for this kind of
product for now at least I think the
plag tower example demonstrates that the
benches we have today are good for
highlighting performance differentials
but they probably won't be the way
you'll likely be playing any of these
games and that's the issue we want to
overcome going forward test system 9800
x3d 6,000 megat transfers per second
cl30 memory high-end Asus x87 e
motherboard all of this isolates GPU
performance which is good but again in
future uh we're aiming to supplement
reviews of a mainstream GPU with a
mainstream PC being tested cuz it kind
of makes sense for The Real World
Experience right um still with all of
those caveats out of the way let's back
on as we are an ultra we're sticking
with 1080p to keep frame rates in
playable territory for the most part but
Intel actually talks about using the
b580 for 1440p gaming and I've got no
problem with that for selected titles
especially with optimized settings and
with upscaling where appropriate the
b580 can definitely do the job so with
all of that out of the way let's start
with a quick look at rate racing
performance which is important for Intel
with the new battle mage architecture
Allen wake 2 here is configured to
maximum raster settings but low RT low
because everything else is using path
tracing remedy is taking no prisoners
here but even low RT is pretty sweet
with uh Reflections and transparency
reflections with a quality level that
exceeds the RT on PS5 Pro all told b580
is the fastest card here by a country
mile 29% clear of RTX 460 51 points
clear of r RX 7600 brutal stuff and I'm
here for it the caveat being frame time
spikes on b580 that can Max at 100
milliseconds and those present as
obvious stutter it's not there on Nvidia
but does seem to impact AMD Avatar
frontiers of Pandora is interesting
there are three parts to this Benchmark
throughout 4060 and b580 are battling it
out delivering broadly similar
performance while the 360 and RX 7600
are left way behind RX 7600 is the card
exhibiting frame time issues this time
around and it's also the least
performant of the bunch as you might
imagine Dying Light 2 on high raate
racing another b580 win 14% ahead of
4060 38 points clear of 360 51% to the
better versus RX
7600 all for
$250 and with 12 gigs of vram now let's
talk f124 with all RT features on and
there are certainly a lot of them Intel
actually issued a driver update to sort
frame time issues which I'll talk about
shortly but not in this game but yeah
well b580 3 points clear of 4060 24%
ahead of 3060 and remarkably it's 3x in
the RX 7600 qos to Cod Masters for
really pushing rate tracing here
everything on Native resolution maximum
settings a 63 FPS average on Arc
b580 Metro Exodus excelled on Arc a770
and a750 back in the day and so it is
here with another Market leading
performance we've got a 58 FPS average
on arcet Extreme settings which is kind
of nuts to be honest with a 16
percentage point lead over the RTX 460
rising to 39 points ahead of the uh 3060
and an almost Cosmic 77% increase in
performance over RX
7600 there's no xss support here though
unfortunately
um I really need to look more closely
into the dlss modding situation for
upscaling Solutions like
xcss kind of retrofitting xcss back into
games that never supported it a plague
to recm RT Shadows next yeah this one
sees b580 bat 460 handily in raster
performance as you'll see a bit later on
and this accumulates into RT as well a
23o lead over 4060 rising to 40% over
3060 and Rising again to a 2.4x
performance multiplier over RX
7600 uh the only Downer is once again no
xcss support that said as soo's own
upscaler is pretty good so look even
maxing everything out like a madman b580
is running rate racing well at 1080p
without using any upscaling from my
perspective this is a major win for a
$250 product I'm genuinely thrilled to
see this kind of comp comptition in a
market where and well let's face facts
here everyone just buys Nvidia anyway if
the steam Hardware survey is to be
believed rate racing requires more RAM
typically and you're getting that and
you're getting great rate racing
performance the one fly in the ointment
during my testing Marvel Spider-Man
Miles Morales whether you're using RT or
no RT the frame times are atrocious
Intel talks about having sorted its
driver issues but well I've got
lingering doubts still let's move on to
raster performance and I'll try to keep
things brief because we're getting very
very close to the Embargo now there's
effective parity between 4060 and b580
in this one but interestingly the RX
7600 starts to flex its muscles it's
almost seven points clear of both the
major contenders here thing is though
that similar to the RT run there is
stutter but it's Intel and AMD that are
most affected while Nvidia is smoother
and more consistent overall RTX 360 b580
has the same 12 gigs of vram and the
Intel card is 18% faster but well once
again no xcss support on this one only
dlss and FSR and while FSR does a job on
this game it's not that pretty this is a
modern title I expect to see xss in it
but it's not black myth Wukong we had to
add it to our Benchmark suite and rather
than use the internal Benchmark sequence
we've used use the intro to the prologue
Which is far more demanding on the GPU
an RTX 460 win here pulling ahead by 9
points over b580 even the 2021 Contender
RTX 3060 delivers 91% of b580 ther
though the RX 7600 Trails b580 is 20%
faster cyberpunk 277 we couldn't use our
RT Benchmark because b580 has issues in
this game when it's paired with an x3d
processor which is a bit of a shame
still here in raster land on Ultra b580
is 23% points clear of RTX 460 36% ahead
of 3060 and it's the RX 7600 that's the
runner up here still rter performance in
this game on Nvidia is notoriously poor
but even so it is what it is which is a
big b580 win not so in f124 with all the
RT loveliness stripped out however
essentially we've got par with RX 7600
and RTX 3060 but the 4060 is 10 points
clear I mean with frame rates this High
that's translating into a 0.7
millisecond per frame advantage on
average for the 4060 which is hardly
gamebreaking though some of the frame
time blips there on b580 are hitting 20
milliseconds which is noticeable you'll
also note that while we're benching the
same content in the moment comparisons
very the gpus are kind of jostling for
position from one scene to the next fors
of horizon 5 now extreme settings long
shutter motion blur the way I like it
atex msaa for those Ultra Clean lines
we're not taking any prisoners here it's
a small 3.5 percentage Point boost for
b580 over RTX 4060 but that's 26% ahead
of the 3060 and 13 points clear of RX
7600 and with a 93.7 FPS average b580 is
clearly doing great here in fact let's
sneak a quick look at 1440p on the same
settings and with the same 8X msaa a 76
FPS average yes these are entry-level
gpus but pick your battles and they can
deliver great quality and excellent
performance and unlike some of the
competition in this lineup b580 is
always above 60 FPS at 1440p extreme
here let's move on to another new game
in our suite the beautiful hellblade 2
maxed Unreal Engine 5 No Holds B and
typically the kind of game we wouldn't
recommend playing at maximum settings
without Dynamic resolution scaling and a
good upscaling solution as well RX 7600
runs very very badly here far worse than
it should be really with some awful
frame time issues and I also note that
the RTX 4060 has occasional lockup too
but looking at b580 Intel's latest is
actually 10% ahead of nvidia's current
budget offering with a 20o lead over the
RTX
3060 Hitman world of assassination next
4060 is up there with RX 7600 both solid
performers while b580 pushes ahead with
a 14-point Advantage versus nvidia's
latest budget offering it would be
cherish of me to point out that the
average frame time difference between
4060 and b580 is just 1.2 milliseconds
on average per frame but yes it it is
another win for b580 a performance
differentials become far more relevant
in a plague toil recream though 27
points 27 percentage points ahead of RTX
460 49 points clear of the 360 basically
we're talking about a 75 FPS average on
b580 while the others are in 40 to 58
FPS territory I haven't really got any
idea what's going on with the plague
Terror results on RX 7600 here there can
be severe St in this sequence along with
generally poor overall performance but
the benches were rerun with similar
results and I can assure you that the RT
result hasn't made its way in by mistake
crazy stuff Spider-Man Miles Morales
though something has gone badly wrong
here just as it did in the raid tracing
test I've tried both of the Intel review
drivers multiple tests but it is what it
is Intel came out saying that drivers
aren't an issue anymore and by and large
my test testing past without issue but
ultimately I'm only testing a tiny
selection of relatively new games so
cyberpunk RT not working properly with
x3d processors Miles Morales just not
working correctly at all I'd venture to
suggest that maybe Intel still has some
work to do since we now have easy access
to power consumption metric via the PCAT
interposer let's take a look this is
actual power dvo measured from both the
pcie slot and the p pcie power input
looking at a PL toil recream here b580
out strips RTX 460 performance as we
know but typically 4060 is in a 120 to
130 wat power range while b580 is
typically pulling 170 to 180 wats so
you're getting a lot more performance
but the power consumption is on a
different level really performance
problems with RX 7600 are reflected in
variable power draw here something is
not quite right that said as we've seen
b580 is also very rapid indeed in the
non rate racing version of cyberpunk
2077 RTX 460 is still in the 120 to 130
watt range but the power draw from b580
varies from 150 to 170 Watts so I find
this quite interesting because we've all
seen power metrics averaged across
Benchmark sequences but the variation in
the moment doesn't quite reflect what
those averages might be telling you the
Delta isn't consistent right even more
intriguing is this Allen wake 2
visualization Arc b580 uh in overall
performance terms it's very close to RTX
4060 performance right actually it's a
bit faster but the typical powered V
seen elsewhere in other games is much
much lower on Intel while staying pretty
much where you'd expect from Nvidia
we've gone from 170 to 180 wat powered D
from b580 in a plague tale to just 140
to 100 50 watts in Allen wake 2 and I'd
love to understand why you'll also note
that across the examples here AMD with
RX 7600 has also been pretty consistent
in the 150 to 160 watt range plague tail
outlier apart final thing I want to
discuss here before I wrap up Legacy
game support Intel has upped its game
here big time since I reviewed uh the
first Arc products I mean I'm probably
one of the only people that still loads
up Assassin's Creed Unity
and it was a disaster area on Intel
arc's launch but Intel remarkably did
fix it but there were still some
concerns let's have a look at Call of
Duty infinite Warfare one of my favorite
Cod campaigns after a Shader compilation
step that is inexplicably lethargic I
mean we're talking about in excess of 20
minutes here the game crashes when you
start the campaign okay it's an old game
but it's not exactly an obscure one and
I'd say that there still driver work to
be done on Legacy titles but I guess my
concern here is that Intel just doesn't
have the Legacy support that Nvidia and
AMD have and I have to wonder whether it
ever will all told though Arc b580 is a
dream product in many ways this is as
close to disruption as you're going to
see a rare thing indeed in a mature
market like PC graphics of course we've
been complaining for years about how
stagnant the sub $300 GPU New Market
segment is um we've been complaining
about 8 gigs of vram not really being
enough we've uh not exactly been
massively happy about gen on- gen
performance increases either b580 is
priced aggressively the price versus
performance ratio is Best in Class rate
racing is excellent xcss is very very
good um just concerned about the lack of
support there and of course Intel is now
shipping xcss 2 frame generation hand on
heart I didn't have time to look at that
in any depth bearing in mind how quickly
we needed to get this review together
but we'll take a look soon in the
meantime though what can I say prior
advice for this class of card was kind
of like a grudging recommendation to get
a 4060 if you have to or pick up a
bargain 3060 for the 12 gigs of memory
dlss is such a crucial feature um b580
makes the decision process a lot more
challenging and let's put it this way
I'm not sure Intel could have done
anything more I don't think it could
have done any better the real niggle is
just how far ahead Nvidia is with
features xcss is great but dlss is
better and the support level for dlss is
Untouchable it's crucial stuff still
that's my review of the b580 it's great
and I've got a very good feeling about
the b570 based on this but for now
that's everything I've got to say or
rather everything I've got time to say
obviously I really want to do more in
terms of the the scope of our GPU
reviews but that's all for me for now
like subscribe share if you feel so
inclined and ring bells for
notifications and a likely algorithmic
boost for digital Foundry content on
YouTube a DF supporter program uh let's
get serious here it's support that means
we can invest in stuff like this brand
new benchmarking technology and in
return you get early access to content
Early Access to DF direct weekly the
chance to help shape the show and much
more including of course high quality
video downloads of everything we do and
have done since late 2016 store.
digitalfoundry is as ever our portal to
our wondrous merchandising Wares but
anyway thanks as ever for watching and
supporting digital Foundry